new rockstars has tweeted us we've been
noticed don't hit the mics this is the
most important new rata Lars video we're
supposed to doing senpai notice you
messed up the intro John you look like a
fool yeah new rock stars tweeted us
saying that we should watch this video
and I've been waiting for ever to get
noticed by these guys best breakdown
channel in the biz and then other
YouTube comments and even a couple of
friends hit me up being like dude you
got to watch a new rock stars video yeah
here we go
I don't even care what the topic is
something about Wolverine and Henry
cattle reports circulating that Henry
Cavill is a stalks for the role all
based on the rock hard evidence that it
reads multiple franchises to contain
castles guns break down everything you
actually need to know about this henry
cavill wolverine news and neuro expert
Kevin Feige surgically enhances with
adamantium claws come on many verses
actually set itself up with semper
always or Logan is beaten buddies to
show up we're gonna kiss my theories and
applying this Henry Cavill Wolverine
movie that will definitely happen after
this Cavalier encountered the Internet
we've been able to trace this all back
to a gossip site with a news article
claiming sources about Henry Cavill as
Wolverine in Captain Marvel - now there
have been some rumors that Marvel has
been meeting with cavil generally as
they do with pretty much everyone in
Hollywood including Keanu but cavils a
bit busy shooting the next season of The
Witcher on Netflix if count is a bit
busy shooting and breathe alone like the
beds one is meeting kids sleeping this
kind of Wolverine rumor is due bloom
sorry there has also been some talk that
Captain Marvel tube will feature a
mutant but a different one rogue based
on the various awesome
the comics that be awesome is true
Captain Marvel - is differently sometime
in 2022 or beyond and I think it's
possible that the MCU reveals with
mutants and possibly the Wolverine
before that in one of the movies in
streamit series we have coming up I see
four series mutants already exist in the
MCU we just haven't been looking hard
yet that's what I've been saying from
the dawn of the MCU Kevin Feige
considered realism what part of his
universe is the whole conspiracy footage
enough sorted mutants series making it
sound like life in the MCU is like a box
of chocolates and you never know if
you're gonna get a Wolverine last time
he trusted a caramel he lost one scene
included this bitching by Tony Stark of
a mysterious shield program and you ship
stuff out of storage
everything from projects Pegasus Exodus
and Goliath later MCU films have
revealed what am i doing Pegasus and
project Goliath work but this is
remaining in history I have speculated
it could be a secret government Weapon X
program and okay so this of mutants from
society to a secure location that now I
know you're saying hey the x-men weren't
the MC the whole time where are they
been what did they help I guess don't
run or Panos yes the canteen I don't
think now that x-men titles are breaking
down my breakdowns I want to be fighting
Loki's tutorial everyone else I'm not
even listening we're behind a pile of
Avengers HQ brothers from getting worse
over the generations like maybe the
Eternals film will reveal that the
deviance of gene look the truth is you
never know what is lurking beyond what's
visible to the naked eye sometimes as
the characters nefarious agenda
sometimes they're just grouchy because
parts of them are tugging other parts
because they haven't been taking care of
those parts yes
[ __ ] look at us we should we be okay we
know we just need the product manscaped
around these parts there's nothing
better for our parts you might even say
our love for the company grows when we
get it to say beaten around the
carefully trimmed bush fix things up a
notch with the brand-new lawn mower 3.0
waterproof body trimmer see it wow wow
that way you can see each pube as you
can okay includes this new lawn mower
3.0 trimmer one of great add-ons to make
for the perfect grooming experience for
the modern man it's gonna cease and
desist us in this video they shed travel
bag in the landscape to boxer-briefs
you're not getting these you're gonna
get your own if you own get 20% off plus
free shipping from your perfect package
3.0 purchase when you use the promo code
new rock at manscape calm
that's code new rock for 20% yes sir
also very special giveaway frozen yes
sir if you insist some canonical mention
of other mutants to buy extraction to
mutants did not exist previously in the
MCU but reset MCU events have created
them and ingame rocket describe the
sentiment remember to pitch what my idea
was introduced because it involves
ridiculously come to of these theories
combine the seen anything like so with
four snaps that's a lot of gamma
radiation spread across the universe
it's gotta be some side effects like say
a child born with tissue regenerative
enough to withstand skeletal adamantium
implant
and the wasps establish that enhanced
abilities like phase-shifting and
healing powers are side effects of
quantum particles adaptation evolution
if the quantum realm exists on a
subatomic level throughout everything
perhaps on a more macro level these
particles exist in higher quantities in
certain life forms which in them result
in mutant abilities abilities that are
now manifesting in individuals
everywhere now that might require the
imputed retcon and change many of the
classic x10 characters origins like you
know Logan actually dates back to the
mid 19th century magneto to world war ii
apocalypse to ancient time a new element
spikey hesitant if he wants to do
something different with the MCU mutant
spike or try to stay true to those
organs
you could try weird Gary 3 mutants
already exist roughly as we know they're
kind of actually that scrawny different
Targ direct way to introduce mutants
into this universes just say the whole
time they've been in a different verse
using time-travel see brothers lived a
second life in the time make sexy and
now boogie appears to be dealing with
the consequences of that in being time
meddling with the time variance
Authority Marvel's time cos coming into
play seen by the TV a could be one in
which among the Avengers we've known our
additional names like Logan Scott
Summers Charles Xavier and that timeline
could be the one Loki tumbles into and
the one we stay in like we leave the
earth one nine nine nine nine behind
forever and stay in earth two hundred
thousand earth-616 whatever you want to
call it but that would be assuming that
the money times are the logic of any
game will be the rules by which the
whole Marvel Universe operates in the
future mutant life can find a better way
for example your very very for Newton's
exist in a different reality of the
multiverse we know from upcoming titles
like Doctor Strange in the multiverse
madness and why do they rewrite the
rules
shattered reality but time travel or
maybe the fabric of reality will be
warped by Scarlet Witch
we've theorized an action of the House
of M event which features wander
resetting reality with and without use
the teaser for the series hinted the
existence of her mutant children Wiccan
and speed do do play a big role in house
of M as does Wolverine Wolverine is the
one mutants who remembers the world as
it was before Wanda flipped reality so
that means are now the dominant social
class and it is on Logan to reawaken
each Marvel hero so that they can flip
things back if this one division series
features Wanda chaotically flipping the
reality through genres as if flipping
through time oh wow the antagonist who
arrives to stop her you know all four of
these theories compare the one with
regenerative nerve cells whose mind
remains intact across the spectrum of
existence and his name is Deadpool I
mean deadpool now right doing rosters at
patreon.com slash new rock stars who do
you think should play Wolverine in the
MCU
Wow God okay
can't believe Eric Voss broke down our
reaction yeah I know right these are all
my thoughts right here that that threw
me for a loop how does he feel
I mean anytime we've been featured in
anyone's videos of someone I admire it's
usually like a split second like a brief
image but I was like oh we were kind of
like call you didn't say real rejects
but we're clearly being called out there
and I was like oh man that's they're
really surprised me from what some
people said I was like okay maybe we got
like a flash of an image like some joke
that man behind is I need to look what
you did you broke him but no my mind yet
totally gap for a second and it took me
a moment to put it together and then I
and then I showed the YouTube page
proper I was just like oh it's just a
YouTube page so that's an honor thank
you Eric Fossum thank you
now let's talk about the new rock stars
video you know for the longest time feel
like a lot of us fans have always had
our theories and our ideas I know how we
would bring like x-men mutants into the
MCU or what you think they might be
doing and stuff like that before endgame
ever came out I would have talked to my
buddies and like my basic idea that I
thought would be a really neat way to
bring them in is before endgame so some
of those would have to change kind of
cuz I always imagined Captain America
having this line of dialogue you know
Captain America's Civil War some people
call that like an Avengers 2.0 kind of
film I felt like you should do some kind
of movie like that where it's not an
Avengers movie but it kind of is it's
like not title that basically they're
seeing the rise of that there's been
some mutants who have existed maybe a
Charles Xavier maybe a Magneto but the
x-men aren't necessarily formed yet so
what you're seeing in this movie is them
learning about the existence of mutants
I always imagine this sort of a dialogue
where you got like Bruce Banner Iron Man
Captain America all talking about these
mutants maybe spider-man's that are too
and they're like you were bitten by a
radioactive spider you were hit by gamma
rays you were a science lab experiment
none of you were born with these
abilities these people are so showing
that this is something in Tyler egged
nipple chills thinking about that just
like that idea of like are they a threat
are they not a threat so exploring from
their perspective non-mutant putting you
in that shoes in that perspective so you
do have some like villainous mutants and
then you have some hero mutants that pop
up in here and you're dealing with that
spectrum but then that's always left
it's tough to the problem but where have
they been this whole time cuz some
mutants are hundreds of years old some
of them have been around for such a long
time and then how do just form the x-men
right then and there so I do think that
kind of combining some of these theories
would help maybe theory number one that
Erik
is talking about the mutants have
already sort of existed combining like
theories than like three and four where
the snap maybe gave birth to more of
them or that the the crossing of the
universes like what they're talking
about in theory number four with
multiverse of madness having that give
rise to like the cellular regeneration
you know whatever the hell they talk
about with you yeah XG yeah things like
that I don't think I'll ever go with
like the kind of idea I have I just
thought it would be smart instead of
introducing the x-men right away I
always thought it would be smarter to
introduce the mutants first in a movie
then you could start introducing your
x-men characters and based off of how
the MCU has sort of been forming how
they had time travel get involved and
now they're gonna be opening up the
multiverse of madness they did explore
alternate timelines already I feel like
theories three and four are the things
I've already personally been leaning on
with how do you properly introduced the
idea of mutants and x-men and all that
into the current existing MCU because
you got to realize that changes
everything
it really changes everything once you
have them in here you know there's a
show my hero academia where can 80% of
the world pretty much has superpowers
80% of the world has quirks
if you introduced the mutants that
creates a whole new political landscape
now because the mutant world of x-men
creates the whole racism dichotomy those
political debates so your whole world
will change where you don't just have
humans and superheroes now you have
human superheroes and mutants you said
your whole and Marvel Universe is gonna
have to shift around so what I'm more
likely to lean towards is degree number
four out of everything he's talking
about and now my four minutes are up
Sean make it fast
yeah whatever they do I just want them
to do something that feels like it's
gonna take a little bit of its time the
only thing that makes me wary about the
you know alternate timeline crashing
into this timeline or a two formed you
know alternate universe being opened
into this one is just that yeah I don't
want to see the x-men just show up in
full formation especially because as
much as I do like the idea that they've
been around in secret or maybe you know
acting on the sidelines to try and
prevent disasters from getting bigger
and more out of hand I do feel like they
have
to have maintained some level of secrecy
because there's also the idea that I
think we already have political debates
in the movies about what those heroes
are doing and also those heroes never
talked about and or reference mutants so
it makes me wonder if going back the
world would truly feel like it had all
these you know other characters in it
yeah aside from those couple Easter Egg
Lions he pointed out it doesn't really
hint at that so for me I would kind of
want it to be something new and I feel
like the snap theory or especially the
idea of coming out of one division I
think that would be pretty smart because
our strange to already has hype and and
generally there's gonna be crossover
with that and one division anyway but
one division I'm sure that if they
introduced the x-men universe somehow
through there yeah that would be a huge
reason for a people just keep tuning in
to Disney Plus but also an interesting
way to marry the TV back together
because the thing is I've been watching
agents of shield and that show and the
tone in the way it handles a lot of
things is very suited to mutants and
there are things in that show where I'm
like yeah basically like watching a
mutant story I think it might be nice if
they existed on a slightly different
scale then the you know huge you know
main flagship hero movies but yeah I
think that something sci-fi and a little
world bending or reality bending is
probably the way that they'll be my
guess yeah I just think it would be
pretty neat though if you know how
generally speaking when you go into an
x-men comic or the show or the first
movies the world already exists with
mutants and there's already this debate
happening with oh do they should should
they exist should they have equal rights
in the yada yada yada
and I think it would be cool if you did
do a movie where the mutants maybe have
existed for a while now they're coming
to the surface so you could watch the
origin of that happening they're coming
out into the public light and then
government's getting involved because if
you know like even if you watch like the
x-men movies there's a time before work
not everyone was aware of them during a
time of like television media already
existed and all that there that they
didn't know about them and then
eventually the world started to learn
about who the mutants are so I think you
still can't introduce it I guess my
concern is that based off of like the
x-men universe there's a huge universe
within just the x-men
verse that you would have to toy with do
one too many origins and kind of not
honor the comics of a lot of the
characters you have that debate of life
with the sokovia accords - we have
heroes or not and now that the world is
loving heroes you know because after the
snap and saving the world at
yada-yada-yada
now you can have a whole different thing
to explore here instead of a new Big
Daddy hmm you have this to really mess
with the world I think you can kind of
fuse both where you have this multiverse
of madness maybe the corner like I think
all of it can actually fuse into one
crazy-ass movie that gives birth to this
new kind of world because maybe there
have been some mutants and now there's a
lot of mutants yeah you know it's
permitting yeah because that can
literally lend itself to the idea of
life iris like the way how people have
perceive mutants to be this disease and
I think there's so many thick elements
you could hone in on with my idea
straight point I think it'd actually be
really cool if rogue was a significant
part of Captain Marvel - sure like that
whole that just bringing up that
plotline really intrigued me last thing
I'll say is I never for one second
believe any of this Henry Cavill Bolton
I never did did anyone want to do a
video about it cuz I'm like this is what
theory are you most likely leaning into
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
to the reel rejects subscribe to new
rockstars click our notification about
like and notified we got our new video
up last but not least patron of the day
ship
yellow dollar bill sign
Logan LeDoux wrote you a poem you
pledged at the end of February but we
got to make it up to you right now so
roaches something special we have a new
patron his name is Logan the real
rejects page he has chosen claims he has
a build like the rock well if that's the
case one day I'll be sucking his yellow
dollar bill fine okay that was a little
extreme but frankly Logan got me being
all crazy like Charlie Sheen sniff my
pheromones cuz you're my Wolverine get
it because of the video what's that
aroma it's the scent of a man from
menace
most certainly has a mysterious persona
I'll drink your milkshake
like a tasty coca-cola Mel doesn't like
the Jews you sneeze and say achoo they
say do the dew I say one day I'll do you
mr. Logan LeDoux Rimes patron of the day
shout out go work John